>> Jon: WELCOME TO "THE
DAILY SHOW."
MY NAME IS JON STEWART.
MY GUEST TONIGHT, ONE OF MY
FAVORITE RAPPERS, ACADEMY AWARD
WINNER, COMMON WILL BE JOINING
US ON THE PROGRAM.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
FIRST, YOU KNOW, SPEAKING OF
COMMON, THE FILM "SELMA," LAST
WEEKEND, WE SAW THE
COMMEMORATION OF THE 50th
ANNIVERSARY OF THE MARCH IN
SELMA.
INCREDIBLY INSPIRING REMINDER OF
THE LENGTHS THAT PEOPLE HAD TO
GO TO DURING THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT FROM SELMA TO THE LUNCH
COUNTER GREENSBORO SIT-INS, TO
THE INTERSTATE BUS FREEDOM
RIDERS.
BUT I BELIEVE IT WAS ISAAC
NEWTON WHO ONCE SAID FOR EVERY
BUS BENDING THE ARC OF THE MORAL
UNIVERSE TOWARDS JUSTICE,
THERE'S ANOTHER BUS COMING IN
THE OPPOSITE DIRECTION.
( LAUGHTER )
TRYING REALLY HARD TO BEND THAT
( BLEEP ) BACK.
( LAUGHTER )
>> A BUS PACKED WITH S.A.E.
FRATERNITY MEMBERS.
YOU CAN HANG THEM FROM A TREE
BUT THEY'LL NEVER SIGN WITH ME
THERE WILL NEVER BE A ( BLEEP )
IN S.A.E.
>> Jon: HA-HA-HA-BOOM!
THAT IS THE UNIVERSITY OF-- THAT
IS THE UNIVERSITY OF OKLAHOMA'S
SIGMA ALPHA EPSILON FRATERNITY
DESCRIBING THEIR RUSH POLICY IN
RACIST CHANT FORM.
NOW, I KNOW WHAT YOU'RE THINKING
AFTER SEEING THAT VIDEO--
LUCKILY, OKLAHOMA LINE BACKER
ERIC STRIKER PUT YOUR FEELING
INTO WORDS.
I'M SO ( BLEEP ) FURIOUS RIGHT
NOW.
S.A.E. JUST ( BLEEP ) IT UP FOR
YOU ALL ( BLEEP ) WHITE
FRATERNITIES.
SAME ( BLEEP ) TALKIN' ABOUT
RACISM DON'T EXIST BE THE SAME
( BLEEP ) THAT BE SHAKIN' OUR
HANDS, GIVIN' US HUGS, TELLIN'
HOW YOU REALLY LOVE US.
( BLEEP ) YOU PHONY ( BLEEP )
FRAUD ( BLEEP ).
( LAUGHTER )
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
>> Jon: I FELT THAT.
( LAUGHTER )
BY THE WAY, PHONY-ASS-BITCHES IS
THOSE KIDS' NEW FRATERNITY.
YOU KNOW WHAT, I GOTTA SAY, I
THINK EVERYONE FELT PRETTY ANGRY
AFTER THIS INCIDENT, BUT
LUCKILY, WE GOT A SPEEDY
APOLOGY.
>> I WAS ANGERED.
I WAS-- YOU KNOW, I WAS
OUTRAGED.
I APOLOGIZE FOR PROFANITY, BUT
I'M NOT APOLOGIZING ABOUT HOW I
FELT BECAUSE THAT'S HOW I FELT
IN MY HEART.
>> Jon: OH, I FORGOT TO
MENTION THE FIRST ONE TO
APOLOGIZE FOR THIS ENTIRE
INCIDENT WASN'T THE BUS FULL OF
RACIST CHANTERS, BUT THE GUY WHO
MADE THE MISTAKE OF SWEARING
WHEN HE REACTED TO THE BUS FULL
OF RACISTS.
( LAUGHTER )
BUT DON'T WORRY, THOSE S.A.E.
KIDS DEEPLY REGRET THAT SOMEONE
FILMED THIS.
>> PARKER RICE, THE FRESH-FACED
FRAT BOY LEADING MEMBERS OF
S.A.E. IN THAT NOW-INFAMOUS
CHANT, IS APOLOGIZING PUBLICLY
WRITING, "I AM DEEPLY SORRY FOR
WHAT I DID SATURDAY NIGHT.
IT WAS WRONG AND RECKLESS.
I MADE A HORRIBLE MISTAKE."
HE GOES ON TO SAY ALCOHOL MAY
HAVE FUELED HIS BAD DECISION
MAKING.
>> Jon: OH, MAY HAVE.
( LAUGHTER )
MAY HAVE.
ALTHOUGH, NOT AS MUCH AS THE
RACISM.
( LAUGHTER )
UNLESS YOU WERE SIPPING ONE OF
THEM "JOHNNY WALKER NO BLACKS."
OR PERHAPS A BUD-WHITE.
WELL, I GUESS THAT'S WHAT YOU
CAN EXPECT WHEN YOU LET YOUNG,
CLUELESS WHITE GUYS RUN AROUND
WITHOUT ANY SUPERVISION.
>> ANOTHER VIDEO HAS SURFACED.
THIS ONE APPEARS TO SHOW THE
FRATERNITY'S 78-YEAR-OLD HOUSE
MOTHER USING THAT SAME RACIAL
SLUR BACK IN 2013.
( BLEEP ), ( BLEEP ), ( BLEEP ),
( BLEEP ).
>> THE FORMER HOUSE MOM, HER
NAME BEAUTON GILBOW,.
( LAUGHTER )
>> Jon: THIS IS TERRIBLE,
BUT I WILL SAY IT IS A BIT OF A
RELIEF WHEN YOU'RE DOING A
HORRIBLE STORY AND EVERYTHING
SEEMS SO DARK, BUT FOR COMIC
RELIEF, IN WALKS FUTON ELBOW.
>> BEAUTON GILBOW.
>> Jon: BON-BON PILLOW.
>> TAUN-TAUN ARMADILLO.
>> BEAUTON GILBOW.
>>
>> Jon: BEYONCE SASPARILLO.
>> BEAUTON GILBOW.
>>
>> Jon: BOCA RATON DILDO.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
I DON'T-- I'M SORRY, I DON'T--
YOU KNOW, THERE WAS OUTRAGE.
>> THEY'RE DISGUSTING.
, THEY'RE HORRIBLE.
>> DISGUSTING AND RACIST.
>> AWFUL.
>> VIOLENT, VULGAR.
>> SICKENING.
>> Jon: YES, IT'S AWFUL AND
THE FRATERNITY CHAPTER WAS
IMMEDIATELY AND RIGHTFULLY
DISBANDED.
TWO PEOPLE EXPELLED FOR THE
DISGRACEFUL DISPLAY.
I MEAN, THERE'S NO EXCUSE FOR
TOR SO YOU WOULD THINK.
>> THE KIDS THAT ARE BUYING
HIP-HOP, IT'S A WHITE AUDIENCE,
AND THEY HEAR THIS OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
>> POPULAR CULTURE BECOMES A
CESSPOOL.
A THE LOVE CORPORATIONS PROFIT
OVER IT-- OFF IT-- AND SOME
PEOPLE ARE DESCRIBED SOME DRUNK
19-YEAR-OLD KIDS REPEAT WHAT
THEY'VE BEEN HEARING.
>> EXACTLY!
>> Jon: TWO THINGS, THE
FIRST OF ALL, THE KIDS ON THAT
BUS WEREN'T REPEATING A RAP SONG
THAT THEY HAD HEARD.
THEY WERE GLEEFULLY PERFORMING
ONE OF THEIR FRATERNITY'S, OH,
LET'S CALL THEM ANTI-NEGRO
SPIRITUALS, FEATURING A WORD
THAT PREDATES RAP AND PROBABLY
FOLK AND THOUGHT.
BLACK RAPPERS DID NOT INTRODUCE
THAT WORD INTO THE VERNACULAR.
AND SECOND OF ALL, HOW COME WHEN
CONSERVATIVES TALK ABOUT AFRICAN
AMERICAN THEY SAY THESE PEOPLE
NEED TO TAKE RESPONSIBILITY,
PULL UP THEIR PANTS AND GET A
JOB.
BUT WHEN WHITE PEOPLE SHOW
RACISM THEY SAY THOSE POOR
CHILDREN DON'T KNOW WRONG FROM
WHITE AFTER BEING DRIF TONE
MADNESS BY THE IRRESISTIBLE
POWER OF HIPPITY-HOPPITY.
( LAUGHTER )
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
AND YOU KNOW, WE HAVE HAD A
STRING OF REALLY PUBLIC RAICHT
INCIDENTS OH, THESE PAST YEARS.
>> CLIVEN BUNDY SUGGESTING THAT
BLACKS MIGHT HAVE BEEN BETTER
OFF UNDER SLAVERY.
>> DONALD STERLING IS ACCUSED OF
MAKING RACIST REMARKS THAT WERE
CAUGHT ON TAPE.
>> A BLISTERING JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT REPORT FOUND A
PATTERN OF RACIAL BIAS IN
FERGUSON POLICING.
>> Jon: ANY TIME ONE OF THESE
COMES TO LIGHT CERTAIN PEOPLE IN
THE MEDIA PRESENT IT NOT AS
BEING INDICATIVE A DEEP,
PROBLEMATIC RACIAL DIVIDE IN OUR
NATION THAT EXISTS TILL TODAY,
BUT AS AN UNENDING SERIES OF
ISOLATED EVENTS.
>> IT'S STERLING'S PROBLEM.
IT'S BUNDY'S PROBLEM.
IT'S NOT THE COUNTRY'S PROBLEM.
>> WE HAVE A BLACK PRESIDENT.
WE HAVE LEADERS OF ALL MAJOR
INDUSTRIES WHO ARE BLACK.
>> IT'S A GENERATIONAL THING.
>> RACISM IS ON ITS LAST LEG.
>> Jon: PRETTY STRONG
( BLEEP ) LEG.
( LAUGHTER )
I THINK IT MIGHT BE-- I THINK IT
MIGHT BE A BIONIC LEG.
( LAUGHTER )
RATHER THAN FACE THE LINGERING
REALITY OF PREJUDICE IN THIS
COUNTRY, EACH INCIDENT, EVEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE'S FERGUSON
REPORT, AS COMPREHENSIVE A
CATALOG OF RACE-BASED PREDATIONS
THAT ANYONE IS GOING TO FIND,
IT'S AN INVITATION TO BEND OVER
BACKWARDS TO NEGATE THE ROLE OF
RACE.
>> BASICALLY WHAT THEY SAID IS
THE FERGUSON POLICE-- FERGUSON
MUNICIPALITY, THE CITY OF
FERGUSON, IS SO DESPERATE FOR
MONEY THAT IT IS ISSUING TONS OF
TRAFFIC CITATIONS, MINOR FIEBZ
THAT ARE ABUSIVE.
SO IT'S NOT A STORY OF
INSTITUTIONAL RACISM IN
FERGUSON.
IT'S A STORY OF BLOOD-SUCK LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THAT'S TRYING TO GET
EVERY OUNCE OF REVENUE THAT IT
CAN.
>> Jon: BY OVERWHELMINGLY
HARASSING BLACK PEOPLE.
NO ACCUMULATION OF RACIST
INCIDENTS IS ENOUGH TO CONVINCE
THESE GUYS THAT RACISM IS STILL
A SOCIETY-WIDE PROBLEM
ESPECIALLY CONSIDERING THE
CONSERVATIVE MEDIA'S WHOLE
BUSINESS MODEL IS GENERALIZING
ISOLATED INCIDENTS.
USING ONE LOBSTER-EATING SURFER
ON FOOD STAMPS TO CONVINCE THEIR
FEARFUL VIEWERS THIS COUNTRY IS
IN THE THROES OF A FREELOADER'S
CHRISTMAS WAR.
I GUESS IN FOX-WORLD POVERTY IS
A CHOICE BUT BEING RACIST IS A
PRODUCT OF YOUR ENVIRONMENT.
( LAUGHTER )
YOU KNOW WHAT?
FEBRUARY WITH THAT IN MIND, I'M
HOPEFUL.
RACISM DENIERS ARE JUST A SLIGHT
INFLECTION AWAY FROM ACTUALLY
UNDERSTANDING THE DEPTH OF THE
REAL PROBLEM.
HERE'S MEGAN KELLY EXPLAINING
WHY FINDING E-MAILS FROM
FERGUSON POLICE SUPERVISORS
COMPARING THE PRESIDENT TO A
CHIMPANZEE IS NOT EVIDENCE OF A
LARGER ISSUE.
>> THERE ARE VERY FEW COMPANIES
IN AMERICA, WHETHER THEY'RE
PUBLIC OR PRIVATE, IN WHICH YOU
CAN SEEK 40 F.B.I. AGENTS ON THE
COMPANY AND REVIEW EVERY EMIL
AND DOCUMENT AND COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN THE EMPLOYEES, YOU WON'T
FIND ANY RACIST E-MAILS, ANY
IPAPPROPRIATE COMMENTS AND TO
TAR THE ENTIRE ORGANIZATION WITH
THAT IS PROBLEMATIC.
>> Jon: IT'S SO CLOSE!
( LAUGHTER )
YOU HAVE THE RIGHT WORDS.
YOUR INFLECTION IS JUST A LITTLE
OFF.
LET ME TRY IT AGAIN.
( CLEARS THROAT )
THERE ARE VERY FEW COMPANIES IN
AMERICA WHERE IF YOU REVIEW
THEIR COMMUNICATIONS YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO FIND RACIST E-MAILS!
YOU SEE THE DIFFERENCE?
YOU SEE THAT?
AND THEN JUST AS A SUGGESTION
YOU COULD TAG THAT SENTENCE
WITH, "HOW ( BLEEP ) UP IS
THAT!"
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.